conditional probability this idea of
thinking about the chance of something
the probability when you have some given
conditions like this is the accuracy of
the test and this is how many people are
likely to have the disease in the
population right these are all
conditions conditions which affect the
probability of something and so this is
a text book literally a textbook example
of what it means to think about
conditional probably and why it's
counterintuitive
so let's think about this from the point
of a simple example what I want to do is
develop your intuition for how
conditional probability works and
hopefully for some of you this will just
ring some bells yeah I remember how this
works and then what we're going to do
which is new is we're going to formalize
that with some some formulas and that
kind of thing okay so example situation
we're gonna say we roll two dice so this
is like as as classical as you can get
for a poverty situation so imagine the
two dice in your hand we roll it okay
here's my first question for you what's
the probability that we that one of the
dice at least one of the dice will be a
six what is the probability of at least
one I should write the word 1/6 okay now
don't tell me yet sir but who raise your
hand if you feel like you have an
instinctive quick response to that I
think I know what the probability is
anyone I'm not gonna ask what it is I
just wanna get a sense of who's gone one
okay interesting all right here's that
when you've got a distinctive
probability that's great okay but for
the vast majority if you don't and even
if you do and you want to confirm it
right we should use tools to confirm to
get a sense of what might this be what
would the calculation be so I'm gonna
ask us to use a tool that we've
introduced before this is called an
array right I want to talk about all of
my sample space and represent it in a
visual form so there are two dice what
are the options on each of the dice what
could I possibly wrong one two three
four five six right so here's one of the
nice one two three four five six and
then I got the other die which happens
to be identical so one two three four
five six now in the past you might have
called an array a dot diagram if you
remember that from stage five so I'm
going to put some dots here each one of
which represents an event that is
equally likely to happen because we're
just assuming they're fair dice okay so
go ahead get this array down with me and
we need to have all these options here I
think I've got reasonably lined up
that'll do
okay so what we think about probability
in general we're always thinking about a
fraction what's on the denominator of
the fraction that's the easy part it's
the size of the sample space all of the
events that could happen and what's
lovely about an array is it just tells
you right there what the sample space is
what the size of it it's how many dots
there are which in this case is 36 very
good so is the easy part now then we
think about the numerator which takes a
little more thought but not that much in
this situation how many times is there a
what we call a favorable event right
that's the thing we're interested in so
on this diagram and you might want to
grab out another color if you've got one
how many times does the favorable event
happen well let's have a look right I'm
looking for sixes right well I can see
it over here if one of the dice dice has
a six then all of these all of these are
favorable events do you agree it's like
cool I got one right but these of course
are not the only ones where are the
others yeah that horizontal row down the
bottom okay so I'm gonna circle these
okay so again what's charming about an
array is it tells you just physically
right how many are there you can just
count the dots how many dots on it there
are 11 right and famously it's not 12
because you don't count this event twice
even though I've circled it twice one
from the row and one from the column and
it's the one event there's only a single
way to roll two sixes so I only count
once so if I so good so there's our
answer
okay and if you feel that if you put
your hand up before you like I had an
intuition that's why I think it is there
well done if you got it right
okay this was not conditional
probability this is just stock standard
probability we didn't
ready excuse me conditions that we
already knew to be true so now I'm going
to reveal some extra bits here okay
suppose it's not you Robbie that I
suppose it's me right I roll the dice
I've got them in my hands and then I
open my head and I show you one of the
dice and I say hey look there's a six
here there's a six in my hand okay
so suppose we say it is known it is
known that there is one six suppose it's
noted that there's one six now I'm going
to ask you the probability of a
different event if this is what we know
what is the probability that we have two
sixes think that for a second is it
enacted again right I've got the two
dice rolled shake it up I show you one
of them and I say hey look this one's a
six what do you think is the chance that
they are both sixes have a think what do
you reckon is he one out of six
one out of six now this is not a bad
guess right because you're like I don't
need to worry about this one but anymore
right in order for this to have both
sixes I really only need to worry about
this guy right and we know the chances
it's a fair die right one in six and one
in six is a good instinctive response
however if you think about what we have
just established this is the whole idea
this is why we all struggle with the
medical example before right it's
actually not the right sample space
right this condition it changes the
sample space right no longer another
color here no longer can I for example
say that this guy here this is
impossible right because I'm already
holding out one of the sixes for you so
you know they can't both be one what
other ones are impossible give me an
example you've got plenty to choose from
two and two also impossible give me
another one three and three also
impossible and we can keep doing this
right you could do it another 25 times
these are all impossible do you agree in
fact the only things that are possible
and when I say possible what we mean is
the only things in the sample space are
the things I have already circled do
great right these things are my new
sample space so when I construct my
lists over here when I construct my
fraction just like I normally do right
when I'm constructing the sample space
down here it's not longer out of 36 it's
not even out of 6 because I'm not
considering a single die on its own I'm
considering both of them together the
conditions affect both so this sample
space is the favored or but you had
before it's it's 11 okay now have a look
again right well as they got right was
the favored event there is only one way
for this to happen but it's not one out
of six it's one out of the eleven that
you've got here does this make sense
which is very counterintuitive but
hopefully this is a good enough argument
for you to convince you that actually
any of these can be possible you didn't
know which die I had in my hand right
that make sense and that's why it could
be this one or it could be that one and
that's a bit counterintuitive but true
nonetheless one at eleven make sense
okay what I'm like you do is think about
formalizing this like which one is that
intuition at the moment and intuition is
helpful but it can also be enormously
untrustworthy